ce soir et pour la dernière fois de
cette campagne électorale j'ai rendez
vous avec la france tout au long de ces
émissions radiotélévisées je me suis
efforcé de vous dire très simplement ce
que je pensais ce que je voulais pour le
pays
j'ai voulu vous montrer ce qu'était le
rôle du chef de l'état dans la
république tel que vous l'avez décider
en votant la constitution de 1958
je crois avoir prouvé que cette
constitution n'a jamais été appliquée et
vous souhaitez certainement comme moi
qu'elle soit la charte durable des
rapports des services publics et du pays
tout entier
mais me suis-je bien expliqué et je
réussis à vous faire partagé ma
conviction car s'il en était autrement
je n'aurais pas remplies matin cho me
direz vous vous êtes un candidat vous
avez voulu présenter votre candidature
vous cherchez à être élu c'est normal il
est vrai mais ce n'était pas croyez moi
l'essentiel de la mission que 1 25 avril
m'ont confié des hommes libres je suis
en effet le seul candidat dans la ce
qu'il est convenu d'appeler la course à
l'élysée qui était désigné par les
autres et non par lui même vous ai-je
bien fait comprendre la gravité de la
décision que vous allez avoir à prendre
et je suis plein d'angoissé car dans une
assez large mesure
si vous n'aviez pas saisi l'importance
du geste que vous allez accomplir
dimanche c'est que je me serais mal
expliqué et pourtant vous le savez ce
que vous allez souverainement décidé en
mettant un bulletin de vote dans les
urnes dimanche
c'est le sort de votre pays pour cette
année cette année c'est long c'est long
dans la vie d'un homme
c'est le temps qui sépare le moment où à
13 ans il prépare son certificat d'étude
du moment où à 20 ans il part au service
militaire c'est long dans la vie d'un
homme
ces longs dans la vie d'une nation la
nôtre a été si cruellement éprouvés par
la plus atroce des guerres qu'elle a
besoin elle a besoin dans toutes les
phases de la société elle a un immense
besoin de repos de sécurité de justice
elle l'a trouvé encore ni la sécurité ni
lé repos ni la justice et j'ai voulu
j'ai voulu vous montrer que c'était dans
le respect le respect souverain des lois
de la république qu'elle pouvait
retrouver cet équilibre qu'elle avait
perdue est ce que j'ai réussi à vous
faire partagé ma conviction profonde
je suis moi-même actuellement très ému
par ce que je sais
étant retourné grande ces images ou
parviendront sur mon terroir charentais
je sais que tous vous attendez que des
jours meilleurs viennent au les joueurs
actuels ne sont pas très sombre mais
confusément vous voyez apparaître ces
années d'efforts que des guerres
personne ne pourra vous éviter mais des
années d'efforts qu'il vous faudra
supporter dans un certain cadre dans un
cadre constitutionnel dans un cadre
légal car il n'est de pays qui
travaillent et qui travaille bien et qui
travaille livre que dans un cadre légal
et le choix que vous allez faire
je vous en supplie ne le fait pas en
considération d'arguments d'arguments
politiques ou d'arguments de faiblesse
oubliez ce que vous pouvez reprocher à
tel candidat là qu'il est trop vieux à
l'autre qu'il est trop jeune au
troisième peut-être qu'il est rampante
les deux qui sèchent préoccupez vous de
choisir le plus capable
on me dirai aussi que c'est un drôle de
langage pour un candidat mais c'est que
dans cette campagne présidentielle je
n'ai pour ma part rien à gagner
je ne suis pas un professionnel de la
politique
je me suis mise à votre disposition je
suis et je resterai toujours à votre
service mais si j'osais je dirais que
j'ai peut-être plus à perdre qu'à gagner
non j'ai tout à gagner j'ai d'abord j'en
suis sûr gagner votre sympathie votre
affection
votre confiance et cela quoi qu'il
advienne cela me restera comme un
immense bienfait
mais ce ne serait pas suffisant si au
delà de cette confiance de cette
affection
je n'avais réussi à vous pénétrez de la
gravité encore une fois je le répèterai
tant que j'aurai quelques instants à
vous parler devant ce petit écran je
vous répéterai la gravité du geste que
vous allez accomplir
et quand je vous disais tout à l'heure
que vous alliez décider du sort du pays
pour sept ans c'est pour bien davantage
en vérité le choix est terrible ou bien
vous allez retomber dans une sorte
d'anarchie politiques ou les intérêts
vont s'entre battre ou bien dans le
sillage du gouvernement précédent
vous verrez surgir et peut-être dans son
entourage
je ne sais quel nouveau guide ou quels
nouveaux maîtres et alors s'en sera fini
de la france tel que nous l'aimons
oui le choix est terrible affaire et si
vous faisiez à vous tromper je sentirai
me remonter à la gorge
le cri des anciens âge que dieu protège
la france
j'ai trois d'émotion actuellement pour
pouvoir vous dire davantage mais tout de
même dans ses derniers moments
je veux vous affirmer que je crois je
crois à la pérennité de notre pays
au-delà de cet automne qui se termine
dans les ouragans
la pluie la tempête elle l'actuel
septennat il y a pour cette france que
nous aimons passionnément tout un
renouveau dont je suis sûre qui sera
fait de sagesse et de liberté
[Musique]